Consider please, this White House scandal from the year 1881. No treason, bribery, or other high crimes and misdemeanors against the state, but the president still did not survive in office for four years. Of course, he had a much bigger problem than any faced by our current president, specifically a bullet in the back. President James A. Garfield was shot by an assassin in July of 1881. But here's the strange thing. Here's where the scandal begins. As he lingered, sick in bed from his infected wound, rumors began, possibly leaks from within the White House.
请思考一下1881年这起白宫丑闻。没有叛国、贿赂或其他危害国家的严重罪行，但总统在任期内却没能活过四年。当然，他面临的问题远比我们现任总统面临的任何问题都要严重得多，具体来说，就是背部中了一枪。詹姆斯·A·加菲尔德总统于1881年7月遭到刺客枪击。但奇怪的地方在于，丑闻也由此开始。当他因伤口感染而在病榻上挣扎时，流言四起，这些流言可能源自白宫内部。
So it's fairly clear from a modern perspective that the man was suffering from infection from the wound.
从现代的角度来看，很明显，他当时正饱受伤口感染的折磨。
Nancy Tomes is a historian at the State University of New York at Stony Brook.
南希·托姆斯是纽约州立大学石溪分校的历史学家。
What's fascinating is that the wound itself was not sufficient to explain what was wrong with him. There was such a long history of popular belief that the White House was a very unhealthy place because of its bad plumbing. The rumor began to circulate that what really was wrong with Garfield was the state of the White House toilets, that they weren't properly hooked up to the sewer system and that he was being poisoned by sewer gas.
令人着迷的是，伤口本身不足以解释他为何会病重。当时社会上流传已久，认为白宫是一个非常不健康的地方，因为那里的管道系统很差。于是开始流传一种说法：加菲尔德真正的问题在于白宫的厕所状况，因为它们没有正确连接到下水道系统，他正在遭受下水道气体的毒害。
Sewer gas. In the 19th century, as indoor plumbing was becoming more and more widespread, it just sort of freaked people out that there was something inside their own houses, this pipe, that connected them to a huge public sewer. It just seemed filthy. And they believed that gases rose from the decaying matter in the sewers, came back up the pipes, and made you sick.
下水道气体。在19世纪，随着室内管道系统日益普及，人们对房屋内部存在某种东西——这种连接着巨大公共下水道的管道——感到非常恐惧。这似乎非常肮脏。他们相信腐烂物质产生的气体从下水道升起，穿过管道回流，让人患病。
And because our nation is of course crazy when it comes to the presidency, because the White House is, among other things, a national movie screen onto which we project a whole array of fears and misplaced idealism, we projected our national fear of sewer gas onto the presidency. The fear was so profound that in June of 1882, the Senate actually voted $300,000 to build a second White House, a second one, a sanitary one, free of filth, right next door to the original White House. And the idea was for his family to just move right in there.
而且，由于我们的国家在对待总统职位的问题上当然是疯狂的，因为白宫不仅是白宫，还是一个投射我们各种恐惧和错位理想主义的全国大银幕，所以我们将对下水道气体的全国性恐惧投射到了总统身上。这种恐惧非常深刻，以至于在1882年6月，参议院竟然投票拨付了30万美元用于建造第二座白宫，一座卫生的、没有污垢的白宫，就在原白宫隔壁。当时的想法是让他的家人直接搬进去。
A lot of this was the work of Chester Arthur, who succeeded Garfield, and who wouldn't live in the White House. He was so convinced that it was unhealthy that he lived in a soldier's home to avoid exposing himself and his family to this danger, the sewer gas.
这其中很大一部分是切斯特·阿瑟的工作，他接替了加菲尔德，而且不愿住在白宫。他坚信那里不健康，所以住进了军人之家，以避免自己和家人暴露在下水道气体这种危险之中。
One of the things that's really amazing reading about this is the way that you write about the press coverage, the equivalent to current tabloids.
阅读相关资料时，最令人惊奇的事情之一是你描写媒体报道的方式，这相当于现在的通俗小报。
Yes.
是的。
A paper company called the New York Herald, at one point they interview what they call a well-known plumber, and you just think-- a well-known plumber? An unnamed source who asserts about Garfield, quote, "The real trouble is sewer gas which is 10 times as bad and even more poisonous than foul air." And this same unnamed source claims there is not a perfect working sewer trap in the executive mansion.
一家名为《纽约先驱报》的报纸，在某一时刻采访了一位所谓的“知名水管工”，你只会觉得——知名水管工？一个匿名消息来源称关于加菲尔德的问题，引述如下：“真正的问题是下水道气体，它比污浊空气糟糕十倍，甚至更有毒。”而这个相同的匿名来源声称，行政官邸里没有一个完善的下水道防臭阀。
Indeed. And the whole concept of a sewer trap, that was to prevent that sewer air from backing up into your home. So an untrapped toilet was the portal of death.
确实。而“下水道防臭阀”这个概念，就是为了防止下水道空气倒流回你的家中。所以一个没有防臭阀的厕所就是死亡之门。
Naturally, this being the United States government, an independent investigator had to be brought in, in this case a sanitary engineer named George Waring, who had made a reputation for himself years before as an expert in these sort of plumbing issues, and could be trusted to issue a nonpartisan, objective report. He found that while there were problems in the White House plumbing system, they were nowhere near as bad as popular rumor had it. He concluded that President Garfield probably did not die of sewer gas, probably the bullet was enough.
自然地，由于这是美国政府，必须引入一位独立调查员，在这种情况下是一位名叫乔治·沃林的卫生工程师，他多年前因在管道问题方面的专业知识而声名鹊起，并且值得信赖，能出具一份无党派的客观报告。他发现虽然白宫管道系统确实存在问题，但远没有坊间传闻的那么严重。他得出结论，加菲尔德总统很可能不是死于下水道气体，大概中枪就已经足够致命了。
The issue was of sufficient public importance that when his final report was issued, long excerpts were published verbatim, even in the New York Times . And one interesting footnote to all this, one of the changes that Waring recommended at the White House in his report, was that they install these new kinds of toilets, toilets of his own design, in this style that was still very new, namely, they were white and they were made of porcelain. And after this, toilets like this became a huge fad, eventually replacing wooden and metal toilets nearly everywhere in this country.
这个问题具有足够的公共重要性，以至于当他的最终报告发布时，即使在《纽约时报》上也逐字刊登了长篇摘录。关于这一切的一个有趣的脚注是，沃林在报告中建议白宫进行的一项改动，就是安装这些新型厕所，这些厕所是他自己设计的，款式非常新颖，即它们是白色的，由瓷器制成。此后，这种厕所成了一种巨大的时尚，最终取代了美国几乎所有地方的木制和金属厕所。
Somehow this association between white and porcelain, it was sold by plumbing contractors, people like Waring who devised these kinds of toilets as safer, because the porcelain would be impervious. Nothing could kind of get in there and fester. And also you could see that it was clean.
不知何故，这种白色和瓷器的结合被管道承包商推销，像沃林这样设计这类厕所的人称其更安全，因为瓷器是不可渗透的。没有什么东西能钻进去滋生细菌。而且你也能看出它是干净的。
Now I bring all this up today, not to talk about the nature of the presidency, but to talk about hysteria and germs. All of this, everything in this story, occurred before the germ theory of disease had been proven. People did not know that germs were the way that disease is spread. That's why they were scared of things like sewer gas.
我今天提出这一切，不是为了谈论总统职位的本质，而是为了谈论歇斯底里和细菌。所有这一切，这个故事中的一切，都发生在疾病细菌学说被证实之前。人们不知道细菌是疾病传播的途径。这就是为什么他们害怕下水道气体之类的东西。
And it would be nice to think that with more information, factual information that we have today about how disease actually spreads, we would all become more rational, take rational precautions to protect ourselves. But the fact is, that is simply not happening. At this very moment, we are experiencing a boom in antibacterial soaps and skin products, antibacterial children's toys and kitchen implements, pizza cutters, and underwear, all marketed to healthy, middle-class people who, if they use the products as intended, will be no healthier as a result of using the products-- most of them. We want to be rational creatures, but we are flawed. We are not rational. And one area we see that all the time is when it comes to germs.
如果认为有了更多信息，有了我们今天关于疾病实际传播方式的事实信息，我们都会变得更加理性，采取理性的预防措施来保护自己，那倒是不错。但事实是，这种情况根本没有发生。此时此刻，我们正在经历抗菌肥皂和护肤产品、抗菌儿童玩具和厨房用具、披萨切割刀和内衣的热潮，所有这些都针对健康的、中产阶级的人群销售，如果他们按预期使用这些产品，大多数人使用这些产品后并不会更健康。我们想成为理性的生物，但我们是有缺陷的。我们并不理性。而在谈到细菌时，我们时刻都能看到这一点。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, germs and our struggle to stay calm in a universe filled with microscopic creatures that can kill us or make us sick.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是：细菌，以及我们在一个充满可能杀死我们或让我们生病的微小生物的世界中保持冷静的斗争。
Act One of our program today, Biblical Thinking in a Digital World. Reporter Hannah Rosen did an investigation of the new antibacterial products. In her investigation, in her report, she mocked them as ineffective. She mocked the people who used them, until one day she went through her own transformation from rationality to irrationality. Act Two, 20th Century Germ. Germs were first understood at the turn of this century. And it turns out that the aesthetics of everyday life in this century, the way that we dress, the way that we groom ourselves, the way that we make our homes, are all the way they are partly in response to this new fangled idea of germs. We explain how.
我们今天节目的第一幕，“数字世界中的圣经思维”。记者汉娜·罗森对这些新型抗菌产品进行了调查。在她的调查和报告中，她嘲笑它们无效。她嘲笑那些使用它们的人，直到有一天她自己经历了一场从理性到非理性的转变。第二幕，“20世纪的细菌”。细菌直到本世纪之交才被首次了解。事实证明，本世纪日常生活的审美——我们的穿着方式、打理自己的方式、建造家园的方式——在某种程度上都是对这种时髦的细菌理念的回应。我们来解释一下原因。
Act Three, Ladies and Germs. We bring you one woman's story. Act Four, You Gonna Eat That? Reporter, author, and farmer Frank Browning on how irrational fear means that you probably are not going to see decent apple cider in your local grocery store this fall. Act Five, The Conqueror Germ. Sean Collins and the germs within us, the germs that can kill us, and the germs that do kill us.
第三幕，“女士们与细菌”。我们将为您讲述一位女性的故事。第四幕，“你真的要吃那个吗？”记者、作家和农场主弗兰克·布朗宁讲述了非理性的恐惧意味着你今年秋天可能在当地杂货店看不到体面的苹果酒。第五幕，“征服者细菌”。肖恩·柯林斯和我们体内的细菌，那些可能杀死我们的细菌，以及确实杀死我们的细菌。
Stay right here.
请保持收听。
Act One, Biblical Thinking. Well our nation goes through waves of germ consciousness. Social reformers at the turn of the century tried to clean up the city slums, prevent the spread of tuberculosis and other diseases. Booker T. Washington proselytized among former slaves about middle-class cleanliness and the gospel of the toothbrush. When reporter Hannah Rosen noticed the latest wave of American germ consciousness kick in, she wrote about it for The New Republic magazine.
第一幕，圣经思维。我们的国家经历过一波波的细菌意识。世纪之交的社会改革者试图清理城市贫民窟，防止结核病和其他疾病的传播。布克·T·华盛顿向前奴隶们传教关于中产阶级的清洁和牙刷的福音。当记者汉娜·罗森注意到最新一波美国细菌意识兴起时，她为《新共和》杂志撰写了相关文章。
I was either in a store buying-- I'm now at the age where some of my friends are having kids or about to have kids-- and I was in the toy store. And I was trying to buy something for someone. And I just noticed that everything was antibacterial. And I thought, hmm, that sounds strange, because kids eat dirt. So what good would it do to have sort of a little antibacterial chair. But there it was. I mean the fire trucks and the things that the kids chew on and the play pens, and everything was suddenly antibacterial.
当时我在商店里买东西——我现在到了周围一些朋友生孩子或者即将生孩子的年纪——我在玩具店里。我试图给别人买点东西。我只是注意到一切都是抗菌的。我想，嗯，这听起来很奇怪，因为孩子们会吃土。所以有一个抗菌的小椅子有什么用呢？但它确实存在。我的意思是消防车、孩子们咀嚼的东西、游戏围栏，所有东西突然间都成了抗菌的。
And I just sort of looked into it. And realized there was just an entire universe, a booming universe of antibacterial products which just-- you could buy anything. You could buy an antibacterial television. In fact, a friend of mine in England had told me that there's an entire antibacterial supermarket. I just started to ask people. And then I realized that it was everywhere.
我只是深入研究了一下。意识到存在着一个完整的宇宙，一个正在蓬勃发展的抗菌产品宇宙——你可以买任何东西。你可以买一个抗菌电视。事实上，我在英国的一个朋友告诉我，有一个完整的抗菌超市。我只是开始问人们。然后我意识到它无处不在。
Let me just ask you to read-- there's a little section in your article where you're explaining the extent of this. And you explain that now antibacterial soaps are 50% of the $2.1 billion soap market. And then you have this little passage where you try to convey how far this has gone.
让我请你读一下——你的文章中有一小部分是你解释这一现象的程度。你解释说现在抗菌肥皂占了21亿美元肥皂市场的50%。然后你有一小段文字，试图表达这一切已经走到了什么程度。
Sure. "It is already possible to spend most of your day in germ-free comfort. You can get a good night's sleep on an antibacterial pillow, snuggled under an antibacterial blanket, brush your teeth with antibacterial toothpaste, take a shower with antibacterial soap, dry off with an antibacterial towel, pull on your antibacterial socks and underwear, eat breakfast on your antibacterial tray, say goodbye to Spot in his antibacterial dog bed, give little Susie her antibacterial toy, grab a cookie from the antibacterial jar, spray the bus seat and your office phone with antibacterial cleaner, then come home and chop up some celery with your antibacterial knife for dinner."
当然。“现在已经可以在大部分时间里生活在无菌的舒适环境中。你可以睡在抗菌枕头上，裹在抗菌毯子里，用抗菌牙膏刷牙，用抗菌肥皂洗澡，用抗菌毛巾擦干，穿上抗菌袜子和内衣，在抗菌托盘上吃早餐，在抗菌狗窝里向 Spot 道别，给小苏西抗菌玩具，从抗菌罐子里抓饼干，用抗菌清洁剂喷洒公交座椅和办公室电话，然后回家用抗菌刀切芹菜当晚餐。”
And the substance of your article really, you spend a lot of time in the article I mean mocking these products and the people who use them. And you argue essentially that for most adults, these things really do nothing.
而你文章的内容确实花费了大量时间嘲笑这些产品和使用它们的人。你本质上认为对于大多数成年人来说，这些东西真的没有什么作用。
Yeah. It's probably that they just oversell themselves. I mean I imagine they don't have zero use. But most scientists say that the major disease risks from ordinary contact with ordinary everyday services and substances, like a table or a scissor or the kinds of things these things are used to protect, are basically zero. If you're a healthy adult, you don't have much risk from just touching things on your desk. And so these products don't do that much good.
是的。它们可能只是过度夸大了自己的作用。我的意思是，我想它们并非毫无用处。但大多数科学家说，由于与普通日常表面和物质（如桌子或剪刀，或者这些东西用来保护的东西）的普通接触而产生的主要疾病风险基本上为零。如果你是一个健康的成年人，仅仅触摸办公桌上的东西并没有太大风险。所以这些产品并没有多大用处。
Another thing you pointed out in your article is that when we get a cold or a flu, what we're getting is a virus--
你在文章中指出的另一件事是，当我们患上感冒或流感时，我们感染的是病毒——
Right.
对。
--which is very different from bacteria, which is what these things are actually targeted at.
——这与细菌非常不同，而细菌正是这些东西实际瞄准的对象。
Right. And that's point two, is that in general a lot of diseases are caused by viruses, not germs. And so these don't help against viruses at all.
对。这是第二点，一般来说很多疾病是由病毒引起的，而不是细菌。所以这些东西对病毒一点帮助都没有。
What about for people with kids? Is there are some legitimate use for some of this stuff?
那对于有孩子的人呢？这些东西里有没有一些合理的用途？
I suppose. But I think even in most cases what will happen is that the kid will get kind of sick. And kids get kind of sick. I mean I don't have kids, but I have friends who have kids. And kids just are constantly getting sick. I mean like I said, kids eat dirt. They chew on each other. There's only so much you can do with a bit of Purell.
我想会有。但我认为即使在大多数情况下，也会发生孩子生病的情况。孩子们总是会生病。我的意思是，我没有孩子，但我有朋友有孩子。孩子们就是不断地生病。我的意思是正如我所说，孩子们吃土。他们互相咀嚼。用一点Purell消毒液所能做的也就这么多。
Let me ask you to talk about Purell? Explain what this product is and explain kind of what you say about it in the article?
让我请你谈谈Purell？解释一下这个产品是什么，并解释一下你在文章中关于它的说法？
Purell seems to be incredibly popular these days. I now see Purell everywhere. It's in airports and just everywhere. So basically, it's an antibacterial hand soap, which is sort of a combination of the alcohol they use in the hospital plus some sort of aloe vera lotion, so it feels good. And the company that started it was a company that actually made hospital products. And they suddenly realized that there was sort of a domestic use for this stuff.
Purell这些天似乎非常受欢迎。我现在到处都能看到Purell。它在机场，到处都是。所以基本上，它是一种抗菌洗手液，有点像是他们在医院使用的酒精加上某种芦荟乳液的混合物，所以感觉不错。而开创这家公司的是一家实际上生产医院产品的公司。他们突然意识到这种东西有一种家庭用途。
And it comes in a pump bottle. And you sort of pump it on your hands and rub it on. And it feels like a lotion, but it's actually meant to kill the bacteria on your hand. So you now have sort of dead bacteria on your hand. It's not sort of preventative. I mean if you touch something else later, you'll just sort of get that thing again.
它装在一个泵瓶里。你把它泵在手上然后揉开。它感觉像乳液，但实际上是为了杀死手上的细菌。所以你现在手上有一堆死细菌。这并不是预防性的。如果以后你触摸了其他东西，你还是会沾上那个东西。
But my problem with Purell was that when they describe the product, they describe it as this sort of sunny, healthy thing. When you talk to the company, they'll talk to you about good family living, and take your kids on a camping trip, or a mother with her diapers. And they'll just describe it as sort of just another part of a Norman Rockwell American life.
但我对Purell的问题在于，当他们描述产品时，他们把它描述成一种阳光、健康的东西。当你与公司交谈时，他们会和你谈论良好的家庭生活，带孩子去露营，或者一个用尿布的母亲。他们会把它描述成诺曼·洛克威尔式美国生活的又一部分。
But then if you look at the actual ads they run, they're clearly meant to appeal to the hassled yuppie in all of us. I mean they show this sort of Petri dish with these office products and some just disgusting looking germs all over your phone and everything. So they're actually meant for people who don't even have time to wash their hands after they go to the bathroom, or who just have four seconds to eat their lunch at their desk and so they have to use Purell, because it takes too much time to go to sink and wash your hands.
但如果你看他们投放的实际广告，它们显然是为了吸引我们每个人内心那个焦虑的雅皮士。我的意思是他们展示了某种带有办公室用品的培养皿，还有你手机和所有东西上那些看起来极其恶心的细菌。所以它们实际上是为那些甚至连上完厕所都没时间洗手的人，或者那些在办公桌上只有四秒钟时间吃午饭的人准备的，所以他们不得不使用Purell，因为去水槽洗手太花时间了。
So their idea that they're not marketing to fear just isn't true. I mean you look at their ads and they're just terrifying. Nobody wants to know that there's this gross stuff on their phone, even if there is. It doesn't do you any good to know that.
所以他们不向恐惧营销的观点是不真实的。你看他们的广告，它们简直令人恐惧。没人想知道他们的手机上有这种恶心的东西，即使确实有。知道这一点对你没有任何好处。
And it might not actually do you any harm, really. There's no proof that it does you any harm if you're a healthy adult.
而且它实际上可能对你没有任何伤害。对于一个健康的成年人来说，没有证据表明它会造成任何伤害。
Right. That's my other thing. I mean all these sort of subway pole ads. I mean once you know that these germs are on your phone or on your desk, you'll never forget that. Every time you look at a subway pole, you'll just imagine it's sort of alive and crawling with maggots and worms. And you'll just have a hard time touching it. So I wish I had never known about this stuff. Because now it's just sort of there in my head. But there's no reason why you ever have to know that your stapler on your desk might have germs on it. It just sort of sounds yucky, even though it's meaningless.
对。这是我的另一点。我的意思是所有那些地铁扶手的广告。一旦你知道这些细菌在你的手机或办公桌上，你就永远不会忘记。每次你看到地铁扶手，你就会想象它仿佛是活着的，爬满了蛆虫和蠕虫。你会觉得很难触摸它。所以我希望我从来不知道这些东西。因为现在它就在我的脑海里。但你完全没有必要知道办公桌上的订书机可能有细菌。即使它毫无意义，听起来也还是很恶心。
Let me ask you to describe what happened. After your article was published, you found that you yourself went through a change.
让我请你描述一下发生了什么。在你的文章发表后，你发现你自己经历了一个变化。
Yeah. Yeah. That was really terrible. It's like after I spent a month, or however long it was, just talking to people at various companies who did research about this, and I suddenly sort of went home and started to worry about what I was using on my cutting board. And should I disinfect my cutting board somehow? Or should we not have rare meat when I was at a restaurant. And just because I knew about this stuff, it's just the image is so gross you feel like you have some knowledge into an underworld. And you just can't somehow banish it from your head.
是的。那真是太可怕了。就好像我花了一个月，或者不管多久，一直在与那些研究过这个问题的公司的人交谈，然后我突然回家开始担心我在砧板上使用什么东西。我是否应该以某种方式对砧板进行消毒？或者当我在餐馆时我们是否不应该吃生肉？仅仅因为我知道了这些东西，画面太恶心了，你觉得你对一个地下世界有了某种了解。你不知何故就是无法把它从你的脑海中驱逐出去。
And I think I'm not the only one this happens to. I mean I mean the germs have gotten a lot of popularity recently. I mean there was a front page story in the New York Times magazine. There was a front page Time magazine story. And it seems to go in waves where every once in awhile, there's sort of a germ phobic panic.
而且我想我不是唯一一个经历这种情况的人。我的意思是细菌最近非常流行。我的意思是《纽约时报》杂志有一篇头版故事。《时代》杂志也有一篇头版故事。而且它似乎是分阶段进行的，每隔一段时间，就会出现一种恐菌恐慌。
One of the things that you write about in these articles is you say, there's a paradox that as society gets cleaner, it searches for germs in even more remote places.
你在这些文章中写到的一点是，你说存在一个悖论：随着社会变得越来越干净，它就在更遥远的地方寻找细菌。
Yeah. That was very interesting. I mean that seems to be a sort of theme of American history. It's moments when we're prosperous, when we're thinking about home life and domesticity. And so we start to turn to the home and its cleanliness. And you start to worry a lot about cleanliness. I mean you'd have these 1950s, lots of home ads, in which you'd have sort of sparkling, clean, shiny products in the home.
是的。那非常有趣。这似乎是美国历史的一个主题。那是我们繁荣的时候，当我们思考家庭生活和家庭事务的时候。所以我们开始转向家庭和它的清洁度。你开始非常担心清洁度。你会有那些1950年代的家庭广告，里面会有闪闪发光的、干净的、光亮的产品。
But one thing I pointed out is that, even in that, there's distinctions because the '50s ads they would be infused with this kind of sense of American progress. Here we are moving forward. This blender will save you X amount of time. This floor cleaner, well, boy, you don't have to bend down anymore. This is the new America. But now with this new household microbiology, it seems to have the exact opposite kind of grim tone to it. We thought we cleaned everything. Well no, we're going backwards now. All these things you thought were clean, were dirty. I think it's almost what happens to police officers who I've known, who start to think that there's danger everywhere, because they spend a lot of time around danger. So they think that world is the world.
但我指出的一点是，即使在那种广告中，也存在区别，因为50年代的广告会被注入一种美国进步的意识。我们正在向前迈进。这个搅拌机能为你节省多少时间。这个地板清洁剂，哦，孩子，你再也不用弯腰了。这就是新美国。但现在，随着这种新的家庭微生物学，它似乎有一种完全相反的严峻基调。我们以为我们把一切都清理干净了。嗯，不，我们现在正在倒退。所有你认为干净的东西，其实都是脏的。我认为这几乎和我知道的那些警察发生的情况一样，他们开始认为到处都有危险，因为他们花了很多时间在危险中。所以他们认为那个世界就是现实。
So after you spent a fair amount of time with scientists who are saying how germs are everywhere and pointing them out, when you would go around, you would literally sort of see and imagine germs everywhere in your environment?
所以当你花了不少时间与那些说细菌无处不在并指出它们的科学家在一起后，当你到处走动时，你真的会以某种方式在环境中看到并想象细菌吗？
Yeah. Like I would go to the gym in the morning and I suddenly thought, oh god, should I sit on this bench? What's going to-- is there going to be bacteria growing between my toes if I take a shower in the gym? And just everywhere, I would be sitting and reading on my couch at home, and just watch for dust balls and think, is there dust balls? Or I cook dinner-- it's like every nice domestic activity was just suddenly ruined. It's just kind of infiltrated by this just horrible underworld that was suddenly kind of crawling up from my floorboards. Yeah.
是的。就像我早上去健身房，我突然想，哦天哪，我应该坐在那条长椅上吗？如果我在健身房洗澡，我的脚趾间会不会长细菌？到处都是，我会在家里的沙发上坐着看书，然后留意灰尘团，心想，有灰尘团吗？或者我做晚饭——就好像每一件美好的家庭活动突然都被毁了。它只是被这个突然从地板下爬出来的恐怖地下世界给渗透了。是的。
You wrote in a second article that you published after the first one, you wrote that you found that you were seized by a kind of dementia. And you wrote that an hour doesn't go by when your hand doesn't stray over to the bottle to squirt Purell on your perfectly clean hands.
你在发表第一篇文章后的第二篇文章中写道，你发现自己被一种痴呆症所攫取。你写道，没有一个小时你的手不去摸那个瓶子，把Purell喷在你完美干净的手上。
And I hate that. I mean what ultimate revenge for Purell that that should happen to me. I mean they'd send me all these products. I mean there was plenty of germ phobic people at my office at the time. So I gave most of them away. But then I couldn't give all of them away. So I just had this little bottle of Purell sitting on my desk.
我讨厌这样。我的意思是对于Purell来说，这发生在我身上是多么大的报复。他们给我寄来了所有这些产品。我的意思是当时我办公室里有很多恐菌的人。所以我把大部分都送人了。但我不能把它们全送人。所以我只是把这一小瓶Purell放在我的桌子上。
And I would notice that if my hands felt sort of a tiny bit clammy or I was like picking up too much newspaper that day, I would just suddenly go over to the Purell and start squeezing it, and then thought, oh, did I have enough? But then knowing that it doesn't actually prevent anything, that maybe I should do it again. Because maybe in the three minutes since I did it last time, there's some bacteria that crawled on my hand.
我会注意到如果我的手感觉有点潮湿，或者那天我读了太多报纸，我就会突然走到Purell前，开始挤它，然后想，哦，我涂够了吗？但后来知道它实际上并不能预防任何事情，也许我应该再涂一次。因为也许在我上次涂完后的三分钟里，有些细菌已经爬到了我的手上。
When you described it, it's almost like it's calling cue from across the room. Come to me.
当你描述它时，它几乎就像是从房间对面发出呼唤。过来。
Maybe that's a good idea. They should have talking Purell.
也许这是个好主意。他们应该生产会说话的Purell。
Then it would be too powerful. No one would be able to resist.
那它就太强大了。没人能抵挡得住。
Exactly.
完全正确。
You know what is so disturbing about all of this is when you talk about the way that information works in this kind of situation, when it comes to germs, that is when you hear about the germs, then you become over-aware of them, and then you act irrationally.
你知道在这种情况下的信息运作方式是多么令人不安，当谈到细菌时，那就是当你听到有关细菌的消息时，你会变得对它们过度敏感，然后你的行为就会变得不理性。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
It's almost like a pre-enlightenment view of what information does to a person. That is, that it won't lead to rational thinking. It won't dispel fear and paranoia, but in fact will lead to fear and paranoia. In a certain way it's very biblical. I mean its very Garden of Eden, that you will get this information. You will eat from the tree of knowledge. And then you will be expelled from paradise.
这几乎就像是对信息对一个人所起作用的启蒙前看法。也就是说，它不会导致理性思考。它不会驱散恐惧和偏执，反而会导致恐惧和偏执。在某种程度上，这非常符合圣经。我的意思是这非常伊甸园，你会得到这些信息。你会吃下知识之树上的果实。然后你就会被逐出天堂。
Right. No, it's true. I mean one thing that writing this has done is transform my understanding of information. I mean I'm a journalist, so the more information the better. I'm not worried about the information at all. But then reading this has made me sort of see information in another way.
对。不，这是真的。我的意思是写作这些东西已经改变了我对信息的理解。我是一名记者，所以信息越多越好。我对信息一点也不担心。但读到这个已经让我以另一种方式看待信息了。
So how's the battle for rational thinking going in your own life? I mean how's it shaping up?
那么你生活中的理性思考之战进行得怎么样？我的意思是它进展如何？
I think it's just sort of fading. I think I've lost a little bit, although not all of my germ consciousness. I mean now I think laziness has triumphed here. The battle still happens, but I'm just too lazy to actually just disinfect my cutting board or wash my hands.
我想它正在逐渐消失。我想我失去了一点点，虽然不是全部的细菌意识。我的意思是现在我想懒惰在这里胜出了。战斗还在发生，但我太懒了，没法真正去给我的砧板消毒或洗手。
Thank god for education. It's the only thing more powerful than fear.
感谢上帝给予教育。它是唯一比恐惧更强大的东西。
Hannah Rosen is now a reporter for the Washington Post.
汉娜·罗森现在是《华盛顿邮报》的记者。
[MUSIC - "GERM FREE ADOLESCENTS" BY X-RAY SPEX]
[音乐 - X-RAY SPEX 的《无菌青少年》]
Act Two, 20th Century Germ. Before people understood about germs, they knew some things about how disease spread, that you could get ill from contact with a very sick person or contact with human waste. But people were not exactly sure how you got ill. They thought that some diseases might just travel through the air, they thought that other diseases might be inherited. There was the whole sewer gas thing.
第二幕，20世纪的细菌。在人们了解细菌之前，他们知道一些关于疾病如何传播的事情，即你可能通过与非常虚弱的人接触或与人类排泄物接触而患病。但人们并不确定你是怎么患病的。他们认为某些疾病可能只是通过空气传播，他们认为其他疾病可能是遗传的。整个下水道气体那码事也是如此。
Then came the germ theory, the notion that there are these tiny living microorganisms that can get on your hands or your clothes and then you can transmit these tiny little living creatures to somebody else by touching them or touching their food or by sneezing or by coughing. All of this was only discovered just before the turn of the 20th century.
然后是细菌学说，这个概念即存在着这些微小的活微生物，它们可以沾到你的手上或衣服上，然后你可以通过触摸它们，或触摸它们的食物，或者通过打喷嚏或咳嗽，将这些微小的活物传播给别人。这一切直到20世纪之交才被发现。
Historian Nancy Tomes has written a book called The Gospel of Germs about how the germ theory spread in America, across America. It turns out that one of the characteristics of the 20th century is that it's the first time in human history that people understood how disease was transmitted and an entire aesthetics emerges, an entire way of living, based on the fact that people now wanted to avoid spreading germs to each other.
历史学家南希·托姆斯写了一本书叫《细菌的福音》，关于细菌学说如何在全美传播。事实证明，20世纪的特征之一是，这是人类历史上第一次人们了解疾病是如何传播的，一种全新的美学出现了，一种全新的生活方式，基于人们现在想要避免互相传播细菌的事实。
Yes, you can see dramatic changes in interior decorations, in home design, in the revolt against a Victorian aesthetic, the plush, the ornate, the dust catching, because dust was one of the vehicles that the new bacteriology pointed to for germs.
是的，你可以看到室内装饰、家居设计、对维多利亚时代审美的反抗、毛绒、华丽、积尘的东西产生了巨大的变化，因为灰尘是新的细菌学指出的细菌携带工具之一。
So what is the aesthetic? What is the emerging aesthetic?
那么这种审美是什么？什么是新兴的审美？
It's stripped down. It's a preference for less, rather than more. It's the use of hard surfaces, light colored surfaces, paint as opposed to wallpaper. Wallpaper was thought to hold germs and to breed germs.
它是极简的。更偏好少即是多。它偏好使用坚硬的表面、浅色的表面、油漆而不是壁纸。人们认为壁纸会吸附细菌并滋生细菌。
And in the bathroom itself, you describe how in Victorian homes, in homes in the last century, the bathroom would basically look like any other room. There'd be rugs, there'd be drapes, there'd be wood everywhere.
而在浴室本身，你描述了维多利亚时代的家中，在上个世纪的家中，浴室基本上看起来像任何其他房间。会有地毯、窗帘，到处都是木头。
The bathroom looked like a little parlor. But when the health reformers get a hold of that, I mean they see all of those rugs and trappings as dangerous vehicles that trap the sewer gas, that silk particles get embedded in there. So you end up with a bathroom that looks much more like our modern conception of a bathroom with porcelain on the floor, porcelain sinks, porcelain toilet fixtures, something that could be easily cleaned with strong soap.
浴室看起来像个小客厅。但当健康改革者接手时，我的意思是他们认为所有那些地毯和陈设都是危险的车辆，会截留下水道气体，丝绸颗粒会嵌入其中。所以你最终得到的浴室看起来更像我们现代对浴室的构想，地板上有瓷器，瓷水槽，瓷厕所装置，可以用强力肥皂轻易清洁的东西。
I mean essentially you arrive at a bathroom which is like an operating room in a hospital. I mean I remember the first time I ever saw an operating room. The thought you have is well, it's exactly like a bathroom, except there's a table.
我的意思是，你最终得到一个像医院手术室一样的浴室。我的意思是，我记得我第一次见到手术室。你的想法是，好吧，它和浴室完全一样，只是多了一张桌子。
Yes, and the stripping down didn't apply just to the home, it also applied to the body and to the clothing. So with women, one of the changes that you see is a shortening of skirts, because long skirts swept along the street, picked up the dust, the dirt, that carried the germs. And there's a big push, starting in the late 19th century, to get a men to shave.
是的，这种极简不仅适用于家庭，也适用于身体和服装。所以对于女性，你看到的变化之一是裙子变短了，因为长裙在街上扫过，沾上了灰尘、污垢，携带了细菌。而且从19世纪末开始，人们大力推动男人刮胡子。
The idea of male authority in the 19th century was a long flowing beard and the mutton chops. And the anti-tuberculosis reformers say to American men, if you love your wife, if you love your child, shave that beard off. Don't give them these germ-laden kisses. And of course Gillette jumps on this, because they think, wait, I'm going to sell them razors.
19世纪男性权威的观念是留着长长的飘逸胡须和络腮胡。而反结核病改革者告诉美国男人，如果你爱你的妻子，如果你爱你的孩子，就刮掉那胡须。不要给他们这些沾满细菌的吻。当然，吉列公司抓住了这一点，因为他们心想，等等，我要向他们卖剃须刀。
Right. Because none of these innovations ever happens without some sort of product tie-in.
对。因为如果没有某种产品关联，这些创新永远不会发生。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Other innovations from the beginning of the age of germs, Kleenex and cellophane, Listerine, named after surgeon Joseph Lister. Also because of anti-tuberculosis activists, you get your own fresh bar of soap in a hotel room and you get clean sheets. And they fold the sheet back over the blanket, so you don't touch the germs on the blanket.
细菌时代开始以来的其他创新，纸巾和玻璃纸，李施德林漱口水，以外科医生约瑟夫·李斯特命名。同样因为反结核病活动家，你在酒店房间里可以拥有自己新鲜的一块肥皂，还能换到干净的床单。他们把床单翻折覆盖在毯子上，这样你就不会碰到毯子上的细菌。
Nancy Tomes' history of all this is called The Gospel of Germs .
南希·托姆斯关于这一切的历史书叫《细菌的福音》。
Act Three, Ladies and Germs. It didn't take very long after the existence and characteristics of germs were proven before public health educators began to talk about the man problem. Men were not being vigilant about preventing the spreading of germs. A study in the 1920s in Muncie, Indiana, noted that men still refused to stop spitting, despite the widespread tuberculosis education campaigns that told them not to spit.
第三幕，女士们与细菌。细菌的存在和特征被证明后没过多久，公共卫生教育者就开始谈论“男人问题”。男人在预防细菌传播方面并不警惕。1920年代印第安纳州曼西的一项研究指出，尽管开展了广泛的结核病教育活动，告诉他们不要随地吐痰，但男人仍然拒绝停止随地吐痰。
And most of the responsibility for preventing the spread of germs fell on women, when they cleaned their homes, when they prepared food. It is no surprise then that psychological studies today indicate that women are more likely than men to develop obsessions over cleaning and over germs. And it can go pretty far. Emily Colas is the author of this amazing and funny, and disturbingly honest account of her own obsession, called Just Checking. We asked her to read a brief excerpt here, as a case study on just how far things can go.
而且预防细菌传播的大部分责任落在了女性身上，当她们清洁家园、准备食物时。那么难怪今天的心理学研究表明，女性比男性更容易产生对清洁和细菌的痴迷。而且这可以走得很远。艾米丽·科拉斯是这本关于她自己对这种痴迷的惊人、有趣且令人不安的诚实记叙《刚刚检查》的作者。我们请她在这里读一小段摘录，作为衡量事情可以发展到多远的一个案例研究。
The TV was on and I wasn't paying attention as I went to turn up the sound, so I was shocked to notice what was on the screen while my hand was still on the volume button. A guy who'd obviously been in a fight, was kneeling down, spitting blood into the snow. I froze in fear for a second, and then became obsessed with the idea that I had somehow contracted a disease from this television encounter. So much so that I was unable to keep it to myself.
电视开着，我没注意，就去调大声音，所以当我的手还在音量按钮上时，我震惊地注意到屏幕上出现了什么。一个显然打过架的家伙，跪在地上，把血吐进雪里。我恐惧地僵住了，随后痴迷于某种通过这次电视遭遇感染了疾病的想法。以至于我无法将其隐瞒。
My husband had always been able to rationalize my fears as either an unusual personality quirk or some hormonal pregnancy problem. But at this moment, he was no longer able to differentiate me from any other crazy person. That night he paced around the house in disbelief, biting his nails and shaking his head from side to side, saying "You don't really believe that, do you? The show was taped months ago. There's no way any disease could live that long in the air. Besides, there's a screen between you and the blood."
我丈夫一直能够把我的恐惧合理化，要么是某种不寻常的个性怪癖，要么是某种荷尔蒙怀孕问题。但此刻，他再也无法把我与其他疯子区别开来。那天晚上，他在屋里焦躁地踱步，咬着指甲，一边摇头一边说：“你不是真的相信那个，对吧？节目是几个月前录制的。没有任何疾病能在空气中存活那么久。此外，屏幕隔开了你和血液。”
My husband and I generally kept a pile of about 20 garbage bags in one corner of our apartment. Which may seem out of character, for me to let them stay, but it was our trash and I knew nothing bad was in there. It was the communal trash that made me shake. So when it was time to take the bags out to the dumpster, my husband had to follow a whole hygienic procedure, to keep the neighbors' germs out of our place.
我和丈夫通常在我们公寓的一个角落里堆着大约20个垃圾袋。这对我来说可能显得格格不入，但我让他们留在那儿，那是我们的垃圾，我知道里面没什么不好的东西。让我颤抖的是公共垃圾。所以当需要把垃圾袋扔到垃圾箱时，我丈夫必须遵循一整套卫生程序，以防止邻居的细菌进入我们的地方。
First the water had to be turned on and left that way, because if you touched the garbage and then the spigot, the spigot would get contaminated. Next he'd take one bag in his right hand and open the door with his left. Then he'd shut the door behind him and lock it, so that no one could get into the house. I guess I could have monitored, but he wanted me upstairs so I couldn't critique him. He'd take the bag down, stand a few feet from the dumpster to be sure not to touch it, and throw the bag in. Then he'd unlock the door, open it, slip his shoes off, come inside, and wash his hands.
首先必须打开水龙头并保持那样，因为如果你触摸了垃圾再触摸水龙头，水龙头就会受到污染。接下来他会右手拿一个袋子，左手开门。然后他会关上身后的门并锁上，这样就没人能进屋了。我想我本来可以监控的，但他想让我呆在楼上，这样我就不能批评他了。他会把袋子拿下去，站在离垃圾箱几英尺远的地方以确保不碰到它，然后把袋子扔进去。然后他会开锁、开门、脱掉鞋子、进来并洗手。
He used a pump soap so that he could use his clean wrist to pump some in the palm of his hand and not contaminate the dispenser. The water would stay on, and he'd move on to the next bag. He went through this procedure 20 times, once for each bag, until they were gone. If contamination occurred at any point during the process, say some brown liquid was on the outside of one of the bags and it got on his shirt, and I saw it, I would not be happy. I would have to go over the scene again and again in my head until I could find a way to convince myself that I wasn't really in danger of getting a disease. I'd inspect myself for cuts that the brown liquid might have gone into, go over the list of things we'd thrown out in the past weeks that could have been brown, or try to remember if anyone had come into our house who might have thrown something away, like a bloody tissue, that could have gotten on me.
他用泵式肥皂，这样他可以用干净的手腕泵一些到手心，而不污染分配器。水会一直开着，他会继续处理下一个袋子。他在这个过程中重复了20次，每个袋子一次，直到它们被清理干净。如果在这个过程中的任何时候发生了污染，比如其中一个袋子的外面有一些棕色液体，而且弄到了他的衬衫上，而我看到了，我会很不高兴。我必须一遍又一遍地在脑海中重复那个场景，直到我能找到一种方法让自己相信我并没有真正面临感染疾病的危险。我会检查自己是否有棕色液体可能进入的伤口，查看过去几周我们扔掉的可能是棕色的东西清单，或者试着回忆是否有人进过我们的房子，可能扔掉了什么东西，比如带血的纸巾，可能弄到了我身上。
If I couldn't shake the fear, I'd ask my husband to go through the discarded trash to find the contaminated bag and try to identify the liquid. He was usually pretty against this, so I had to beg. It was all I'd talk about for hours, and I guess in an effort to just shut me up, he'd relent. Of course, this trip was considered highly unsanitary and called for special protective measures. He had to put on clothes that he'd be willing to get rid of and carry paper towels so his hands wouldn't touch the bag directly. When he was finished with his inspection, he had to take off his clothes outside our front door, leave them to be thrown away, come in and do a double hand wash. Then I'd turn the shower on and he'd finish cleaning off.
如果我无法摆脱这种恐惧，我会让我丈夫去翻找丢弃的垃圾，找到那个被污染的袋子并试图鉴定那种液体。他通常非常反对这一点，所以我不得不哀求。我几个小时谈论的都是这个，我想为了让我闭嘴，他会同意的。当然，这次行程被认为是非常不卫生的，需要采取特殊的防护措施。他必须穿上他愿意丢掉的衣服，并带上纸巾，这样他的手就不会直接碰到袋子。当他完成检查后，他必须在我们的前门外脱掉衣服，留下它们等待被丢弃，进来并进行双重洗手。然后我会打开淋浴，他会完成清理。
I'd sit on the edge of the bed and wait for him to finish, so he could deliver his report. On this day, he identified the liquid as hamburger juice. A particularly insidious liquid that is close to the color and texture of human blood. My husband said that he smelled and tasted it and was sure that it was indeed from a cow. Looking back, I'm a little surprised that it was four more years before we separated.
我坐在床边等他完成，这样他就可以提交报告。在那一天，他鉴定这种液体是汉堡肉汁。一种特别阴险的液体，颜色和质地接近人的血液。我丈夫说他闻了闻，尝了尝，确信它确实来自一头牛。回首往事，我有点惊讶四年后我们才分居。
Emily Colas. Her book is called Just Checking.
艾米丽·科拉斯。她的书名是《刚刚检查》。
Coming up, if a germ does kill you, what does the germ get out of it? Also impure food, impure thoughts. That's in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果一种细菌杀死了你，它能从中得到什么？还有不纯的食物，不纯的思想。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Welcome there, ladies and germs. So that's the great thing about today's theme is I get to say ladies and germs as many times as I want. A privilege you don't get very often in public radio. Each week on our program of course, which choose a theme, Ladies and Germs, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, germs and why they make us leave the world of rationality for irrationality. We have arrived at Act Four of our program, Act Four, You Gonna Eat That?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。欢迎来到这里，女士们和细菌们。所以这就是今天主题的伟大之处，我可以想说多少次“女士们和细菌们”就说多少次。这是你在公共广播中很少得到的特权。每周我们的节目当然都会选择一个主题，“女士们和细菌们”，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是：细菌以及为什么它们让我们离开理性世界走向非理性。我们已经到达节目的第四幕，第四幕，“你真的要吃那个吗？”
One of the places that we fear germ contamination, is of course in our food, but of course this fear is not always justified. For example this fall, this very fall, chances are you will not be able to find fresh apple cider in your local grocery store. Now I'm talking about the stuff that comes straight from the farm, unpasteurized, dark brown. Usually it's this very careful blend of four or five different kinds of apples based on some farm family's old recipe.
我们害怕细菌污染的地方之一，当然是在我们的食物中，但这种恐惧并不总是合理的。例如今年秋天，就在今年秋天，你很可能无法在当地杂货店找到新鲜苹果酒。现在我说的是那些直接来自农场、未经过巴氏杀菌、深褐色的东西。通常这是基于某些农场家庭古老配方，由四五种不同苹果精心混合而成的。
Unpasteurized cider like this only makes up 3% to 5% of the nation's cider, but it is becoming harder and harder to find. And the reason-- Frank Browning is a reporter who often covers public health stories. He answers the question.
像这样的未巴氏杀菌苹果酒只占全国苹果酒的3%到5%，但它正变得越来越难找到。而原因——弗兰克·布朗宁是一位经常报道公共卫生故事的记者。他回答了这个问题。
First, truth in labeling. I'm not just an objective journalist. I have a farmer's bias. My brother and I grow apples on a hilltop in eastern Kentucky. And we make cider. This year, as last year and the year before that, we've been hauling our cider down to the Kentucky State Fair in Louisville.
首先，标签上的事实。我不只是一个客观的记者。我有农场主的偏见。我和我哥哥在肯塔基州东部的一个山顶上种苹果。我们制作苹果酒。今年，像去年和前一年一样，我们一直把我们的苹果酒拖到路易斯维尔的肯塔基州博览会。
Is that good?
那个好喝吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Here I am at the ag-produce tent, talking cider slushies.
我现在在农产品帐篷里，谈论苹果酒冰沙。
Apple cider slushies. Come get a free taste. Can't go wrong free. It's nothing but pure apple juice. People love them once they taste it.
苹果酒冰沙。来免费品尝吧。免费的准没错。它除了纯苹果汁什么都没有。人们尝过之后都会爱上它。
When you drink one of our slushies, or for that matter when you draw a plain cup of fresh cider to your lips, we want to steal away all those awful memories you've accumulated of insipid canned apple juice. Tasting fresh cider should be like a eating a handful of autumn, honeyed and tart, nutty, spicy, playfully fragrant. It should play mischief with memory as it trickles across your tongue, washes over the palate, and makes you giggle silently at how exquisite of a treasure of the ordinary earth. But as I say, I'm biased.
当你喝我们的冰沙时，或者就此而言，当你把一杯新鲜的普通苹果酒送到嘴边时，我们想窃走你积累的所有关于淡而无味的罐装苹果汁的糟糕记忆。品尝新鲜苹果酒应该就像吃一把秋天，蜂蜜味和酸味，坚果味，辛辣味，俏皮的芬芳。它应该在你舌尖流淌、拂过味蕾时戏弄记忆，让你对平凡大地是何等精致的珍宝而暗自窃笑。但正如我所说，我有偏见。
Then came E. coli O157:H7. You've read about it in the papers, or heard about it on the nightly TV terror news. The great cider contamination scare. Like most apple growers, we saw the same stories. And we wondered, had cider fallen victim to that front line of bacterial armageddon that threatens all our collective fate? So I called up Joe O'Leary, the food safety scientist at our state Farm Extension Service at the University of Kentucky, and told him we were worried and confused about cider's health risks.
然后是大肠杆菌O157:H7出现了。你在报纸上读到过，或者在每晚的电视恐怖新闻中听到过。伟大的苹果酒污染恐慌。像大多数苹果种植者一样，我们看到了同样的故事。我们想知道，苹果酒是否成为了威胁我们所有集体命运的那条细菌世界末日前线的受害者？所以我打电话给肯塔基大学我们州农业推广服务中心的食品安全科学家乔·奥利里，告诉他我们对苹果酒的健康风险感到担心和困惑。
Well, you and a lot of other people. But the number of instances has really been extremely low. When you look at the number of small operators, and the number that have been a problem, it's only about three or four in this country in a 20-year period, and then there were one or two in Canada as well. And it may be a risk, but it's a fairly slight risk. But again, we've got to be concerned about these little children that could drink this.
嗯，你和其他很多人一样。但实例的数量确实非常非常少。当你观察小经营者的数量，以及出现问题的数量，在20年期间这个国家只有三四个，加拿大也有一两个。它可能是一种风险，但风险相当小。但同样，我们必须关心这些可能喝它的幼儿。
The problem is Odwalla. Isn't that a splendid name? Liquid beacon to the organo-yuppies of the health food movement, all natural, all organic juices, until somebody dumped a load or two of rotting fruit, presumably organic, into the mill and forgot to follow the company's own sanitizing procedures. And a little girl in Colorado drank that organic health food juice and died from E. coli poisoning. A million and a half bucks Odwalla paid to settle the matter.
问题是Odwalla。那名字不是很棒吗？健康食品运动中原生态雅皮士的液体灯塔，全天然，全有机果汁，直到有人把一两卡车腐烂的水果——大概是有机的——倒进磨坊，忘了遵循公司自己的消毒程序。科罗拉多州的一个小女孩喝了那种有机健康食品果汁，死于大肠杆菌中毒。Odwalla支付了150万美元来解决这件事。
There had been four other E. coli cases on small farms, all of them were traced to using apples we call drops, that have fallen on the ground and haven't been washed. Then you put that together with bad hamburgers, dirty sprouts, lettuce, contaminated berries from Guatemala-- never mind how great the actual risk is in epidemiological terms-- and we Americans brewed up a full-fledged food panic. In all the media coverage, there's something probably nobody told you. Cider can be produced safely and without pasteurization.
小农场还有其他四起大肠杆菌病例，所有病例都被追踪到使用了我们称之为“落地果”的苹果，即掉在地上还没洗过的苹果。然后你把那和坏汉堡、脏豆芽、生菜、来自危地马拉的受污染浆果放在一起——不管流行病学意义上的实际风险有多大——我们美国人酿成了一场彻头彻尾的食品恐慌。在所有的媒体报道中，有些事情可能没人告诉你。苹果酒可以安全生产，无需巴氏杀菌。
Now here's what family farms like ours do. We never use drops. We wash all our equipment down in high acid, dairy grade detergent, followed with a chlorine rinse. Then we run the apples themselves through a chlorine wash, just before grinding and pressing. All of that makes unpasteurized apple cider thoroughly safe. Unfortunately, in the hour of hysteria, that isn't enough.
现在这是像我们这样的家庭农场所做的。我们从不使用落地果。我们用高酸度、乳制品级洗涤剂清洗所有设备，然后进行氯冲洗。然后我们在研磨和压榨之前，让苹果通过氯洗。所有这些使未经巴氏杀菌的苹果酒非常安全。不幸的是，在歇斯底里的时刻，这还不够。
Here's how far it's gone. Ohio apple growers found themselves drowning in the full scale cider panic last year, organized by the State Agriculture Department. My friend Mitch Lynd, Ohio's biggest apple grower, told me the story.
事情已经发展到这一步了。去年，俄亥俄州的苹果种植者发现自己淹没在由州农业部组织的全面苹果酒恐慌中。我的朋友米奇·林德，俄亥俄州最大的苹果种植者，给我讲了这个故事。
Well, the doggone-- as a result of this E. coli thing out of Colorado, this one incident, why the decision was made that maybe they ought to impose pasteurization on all these cider makers. Next thing we knew, we're called into this meeting and in effect we were told now, you fellas don't have to pasteurize. But we're going to advise the schools, saying now, don't let your children drink the cider from any of these farms or orchards if it hasn't been pasteurized.
嗯，该死的——作为科罗拉多州大肠杆菌事件的结果，这起单一事件，为什么决定 imposition 对所有这些苹果酒制造者实施巴氏杀菌。下一件事我们知道，我们被叫去开这个会，实际上我们被告知，你们这些家伙不一定要做巴氏杀菌。但我们将建议学校说，别让你们的孩子喝任何这些农场或果园的苹果酒，如果它没有经过巴氏杀菌的话。
Ohio officials admitted the cider was safe. But said they were going to go ahead and scare people anyway.
俄亥俄州官员承认苹果酒是安全的。但说他们打算继续吓唬人。
And their attitude was that if they're going to be wrong, they want to err on the side of safety. Well, it's like saying which is more safe, to drink two drops of beer before you drive down the road or one drop of beer before you drive down the road? One's twice as safe as the other, but neither one's very hazardous, you see.
而他们的态度是，如果他们要犯错，他们宁愿在安全方面犯错。这就像说哪个更安全，在你开车上路前喝两滴啤酒，还是在你开车上路前喝一滴啤酒？一个是另一个的两倍安全，但两者都不是特别危险，你看。
Time to call that state official, the one who read the riot act to all the growers. That would be Sam Waltz of the Ohio Department of Agriculture, a very nice man, who confirms that well, yes, there's never been a case of food poisoning from cider in his state.
是时候打电话给那个州官员了，那个对所有种植者宣读处罚条例的人。那是俄亥俄州农业部的山姆·瓦尔兹，一个非常好的人，他证实，嗯，是的，他的州从来没有发生过苹果酒导致的食物中毒案件。
Yes. We've never had, that we're aware of, a case of food poisoning from any bacteria that was attributed to cider. And we had a situation here in Columbus that was kind of unique. There was about 10 cases of human E. coli O157:H7 food poisoning reported in Columbus.
是的。据我们所知，我们从来没有发生过任何归因于苹果酒的细菌导致的食物中毒案件。我们在哥伦布有一个情况有点独特。哥伦布报告了大约10例人类大肠杆菌O157:H7食物中毒案件。
And what kind of food product was this?
那是哪种食品？
Well, early on one of the common foods that many of the 10 or so infected people had consumed was fresh cider. And there was a leak to the press-- don't know really where it came from-- that was covering this quite heavily at the time, a leak to the local press saying that cider was suspected. Of course, the investigation was not complete. And later on it was shown that cider was not the likely culprit, that more than likely it was some lettuce. But the fact that it leaked into the press that cider was a suspect food, fresh cider sales in the city of Columbus, which is a large market in our state, dropped by about 2/3 overnight. And just didn't recover for the rest of that season.
嗯，早些时候，10名左右受感染者中的许多人食用过的一种常见食物是新鲜苹果酒。媒体有泄密——我真的不知道它来自哪里——当时这方面报道非常多，泄密给当地媒体说苹果酒受到怀疑。当然，调查还没有完成。后来证明苹果酒不是可能的罪魁祸首，更有可能是某些生菜。但泄露给媒体说苹果酒是一种可疑食物的事实，俄亥俄州哥伦布市的新鲜苹果酒销量，这是一个我们州的大市场，一夜之间下降了大约2/3。而且那个季节剩下的时间里就没恢复过来。
And so then you contacted the media and urged them to press this issue?
所以你联系了媒体并敦促他们报道这个问题？
Yes.
是的。
How did that go?
进展如何？
It really went well. And the media was good to pick up on this. And it showed up in a lot of newsprint.
确实进展得很顺利。媒体很好地跟进了这个。它出现在很多新闻纸上。
And what did it say?
上面说了什么？
Basically positive that E. coli may be a hazard in cider, very rare. But that the cider industry here in Ohio is being proactive to do whatever they can to learn and employ techniques that will produce safe cider.
基本上是积极的，即大肠杆菌在苹果酒中可能是一种危险，非常罕见。但俄亥俄州的苹果酒行业正在主动采取一切他们能采取的措施，学习和采用技术，生产安全的苹果酒。
But that included pretty much urging people not to drink unpasteurized cider, didn't it?
但这基本上包括敦促人们不要喝未经过巴氏杀菌的苹果酒，不是吗？
Ahh yes, and-- well, we took the position that if it's produced properly with proper sanitation, that unpasteurized cider is not a problem.
啊，是的，而且——嗯，我们采取的立场是，如果它是以正确的卫生条件正确生产的，那么未经过巴氏杀菌的苹果酒就不是问题。
Not a problem. Well, except that the main point of the press campaign was to convince parents that serving unpasteurized cider might kill their kids. None of it made any sense. And then I remembered something else Joe O'Leary, the food scientist from UK, said to me.
不是问题。嗯，除了媒体运动的主要目的是说服父母提供未经过巴氏杀菌的苹果酒可能会杀死他们的孩子。这一切毫无道理。然后我记起了肯塔基大学食品科学家乔·奥利里对我说的另一件事。
Well, another consideration is that these commercial juice processors, the really big outfits, they see the small farm cider operations as a threat in this. They're bringing bad publicity on the industry. And so that's one of the reasons why they are in favor of all these changes, in my opinion.
嗯，另一个考虑是这些商业果汁加工商，那些真正的大机构，他们把小农场苹果酒作业看作是这方面的威胁。他们给行业带来了坏名声。所以这就是他们支持所有这些变化的原因之一，在我看来。
So you think the big operators basically want to squeeze the little guys out?
所以你认为大运营商基本上想把小家伙挤出去？
Well, that's always the case, isn't it?
嗯，情况一直如此，不是吗？
Hmm, I said to myself. I've spent my life writing and reporting about the politics of money, the politics of health, even politics and agriculture. But somehow, my farmer self hadn't imagined that politics had crawled inside the rustic cider jug. What small growers have always supposed is that we're such a minuscule part of the juice biz that big processing companies and their Washington lobbyists never thought about us at all.
嗯，我对自己说。我一生都在写和报道关于金钱政治、健康政治，甚至农业政治。但不知何故，我的农夫自我并没有想象到政治已经爬进了乡村苹果酒壶里。小种植者一直假设我们在果汁行业中只是微不足道的一部分，大加工公司和他们在华盛顿的游说者根本没想过我们。
The heavy hitters in the American apple kingdom are in Washington state, Michigan, and New York. And they have a club, the US Apple Association. I call it Big Apple. It includes national packers and processors, and of course fields a clutch of lobbyists in Washington. And where do you suppose Big Apple stood on the pro-pasteurization cider crackdown? They lobbied against the FDA's decision this year to permit small growers to sell untreated juice, even if it is produced under sanitary conditions and labeled as unpasteurized.
美国苹果王国的重量级人物在华盛顿州、密歇根州和纽约。他们有一个俱乐部，美国苹果协会。我称之为“大苹果”。它包括全国性的包装商和加工商，当然在华盛顿部署了一群游说者。你认为“大苹果”在巴氏杀菌苹果酒打压行动中站在哪里？他们游说反对食品药品监督管理局今年允许小种植者销售未处理果汁的决定，即使它是在卫生条件下生产并标记为未巴氏杀菌的。
Who else has been driving the pasteurization campaign? Another Washington lobbying group, the National Food Processors Association, which modestly represents many of the world's largest multinational food conglomerates. Tom Willard, the Processors' spokesman, was off at a conference when he called me back. He only wanted to talk safety.
还有谁在推动巴氏杀菌运动？另一个华盛顿游说团体，国家食品加工者协会，它适度地代表了世界上许多最大的跨国食品集团。加工者发言人汤姆·威拉德在我给他回电话时正要去参加一个会议。他只想谈论安全。
Well, food safety really affects everyone. If a consumer were to be made ill by a particular product, they could lose track of the fact whether it was pasteurized or not. That has a tendency to damage the reputation of all people in that sector. It's why we feel it's important that all juices be pasteurized. The food industry spends many, many millions of dollars a year to ensure that what they do to their products renders them as safe as possible. We think that if there is a safe and effective technology out there that can further ensure US food safety, it should be applied.
嗯，食品安全确实影响到每个人。如果消费者因特定产品而生病，他们可能会忘记该产品是否经过巴氏杀菌。这往往会损害该领域所有人的声誉。这就是为什么我们认为所有果汁都经过巴氏杀菌很重要。食品行业每年花费数千万美元来确保他们对产品所做的处理使其尽可能安全。我们认为如果有某种安全有效的技术可以进一步确保美国食品安全，就应该应用它。
Now I've spoken to a number of public health people, and they basically have said to me, you have a maximum of four E. coli cases ever in the history of the country, out of millions, probably billions, of gallons of cider that's been sold. And that this is another one of those cases of nutty American food panics.
现在我已经和一些公共卫生人士谈过了，他们基本上告诉我，你在这个国家的历史上总共最多只有四起大肠杆菌病例，在数百万，可能数十亿加仑已售出的苹果酒中。而且这是又一起疯狂的美国食品恐慌案例。
Well, I think that if you turn the situation around and say, here was a product that only caused three or four cases of illness anywhere. The question is not is that relatively few, but is there something effective that you know you can do that would render this completely free of that-- that that would not be an issue anymore. If there is an existing technology that is there that can be applied and is widely being applied, we don't really see why you wouldn't go ahead and require it.
嗯，我认为如果你扭转局势说，这是一个只导致了三四起疾病的产品。问题不在于这是否相对较少，而在于你知道你能采取什么有效措施，能使这完全免除这个问题——那将不再是一个问题。如果现有的技术存在并且可以被应用，而且被广泛应用，我们真的看不出你为什么不去做并要求它。
Meaning, in plain talk, the producers who invented and control global brand identity prefer to eliminate everybody who does not have the capital or the market share to compete. Forcing independent apple growers to spend $25,000 or $30,000 on pasteurization equipment would drive about 3/4 of today's cider makers out of business. But then as I have said, I'm biased.
也就是说，用通俗的话说，发明并控制全球品牌标识的生产商宁愿消灭所有没有资本或市场份额去竞争的人。迫使独立苹果种植者花费25,000或30,000美元购买巴氏杀菌设备将使今天大约3/4的苹果酒制造者破产。但正如我所说，我有偏见。
Now presumably, from Big Apple's point of view, it's better that way. Then consumers have nothing to judge Mott's and Tree Top and Red Chief against. When Americans panic over microbial contamination, it isn't market neutral. It boosts big business.
现在据推测，从“大苹果”的角度来看，那样更好。然后消费者就没什么可以用来评判Mott's、Tree Top和Red Chief的了。当美国人对微生物污染感到恐慌时，它不是市场中立的。它促进了大企业。
The campaign of fear is working. I called up the one city market where we sell our apples and cider, Pipkin's produce in Cincinnati and talked to Ben Pipkin.
恐惧运动正在奏效。我打电话给那个我们销售苹果和苹果酒的城市市场，辛辛那提的Pipkin's produce，和本·皮普金谈了谈。
So Ben, what's been happening to cider sales this year?
那么本，今年苹果酒销量怎么样？
Cider sales this year, well, we're just getting ready to start on cider this year. Last year, sales were probably about, on the unpasteurized cider, about half of what they were last year. Yeah.
今年的苹果酒销量，嗯，我们正准备开始做苹果酒。去年，未经过巴氏杀菌苹果酒的销量，大概是前一年的一半。是的。
We made our first delivery of the season to Ben the day of my phone call. And he told us that customers were lining up at the loading dock to buy the new fresh cider. Then over the weekend, the local press ran its by now annual panic stories. Ben's customers started wrinkling their brows with concern. Well, why not? If I knew nothing about growing applies, if I hadn't seen our sanitation system, and if every time I picked up the paper to read about cider, I was told about a little girl who died Colorado, I'd panic about drinking cider too.
我们在我打电话的那天给本送了第一批货。他告诉我们，客户在装货码头排队购买新的新鲜苹果酒。然后周末，当地媒体刊登了它如今已是年度惯例的恐慌故事。本的客户开始皱着眉头感到担忧。好吧，为什么不呢？如果我对种植苹果一无所知，如果我没见过我们的卫生系统，如果每次我拿起报纸读到关于苹果酒的事，我都被告知科罗拉多州一个小女孩死了，我也会对喝苹果酒感到恐慌。
Panics, whether about food, sex, or politics, require two essential conditions. First, the trigger must be something that hits us very close to home. Second, the object of the panic must be something we really don't understand. With fewer than 3% of the American population actively farming, few of us have any idea what it takes to lure plants out of the ground, or how it is that they find their way to the local supermarket's produce shelf.
恐慌，无论是关于食物、性还是政治，都需要两个基本条件。首先，触发因素必须是与我们息息相关的事情。其次，恐慌的对象必须是我们真的不了解的事情。随着少于3%的美国人口积极从事农业，我们很少有人知道把植物从地里引出来需要什么，或者它们是如何找到通往当地超市农产品货架的路径的。
And so we make myths, in this case of unseen microorganisms threatening our families. And we live by those myths, afraid of what we don't know. And it turns out for all too many people, the world of unseen, unexplained phenomena includes apple cider.
所以我们制造神话，在这种情况下是看不见的微生物威胁我们的家庭。我们生活在那些神话中，害怕我们所不知道的东西。事实证明，对太多人来说，看不见的、无法解释的现象世界包括苹果酒。
Frank Browning's latest book is called Apples. His family orchard is in Kentucky.
弗兰克·布朗宁的最新书叫《苹果》。他的家庭果园在肯塔基州。
[MUSIC - "COMFORT ME WITH APPLES" BY INDIA ADAMS]
[音乐 - INDIA ADAMS 的《用苹果安慰我》]
Act Five. The Conqueror Germ.
第五幕。征服者细菌。
More often than not, we use the language of war when we talk about disease. Someone is said to battle cancer or to fight an infection. The truth is, the metaphor is an apt one. In the case of my friend Christopher, the germ won. It took some 15 years to happen, but it won. It didn't win each battle, but it won the war.
大多数时候，我们在谈论疾病时使用战争语言。有人说与癌症抗争或对抗感染。事实是，这个比喻很贴切。就我朋友克里斯托弗而言，细菌赢了。花了大约15年才发生，但它赢了。它没有赢得每场战斗，但它赢得了战争。
Now this story of the germs within us, and what we fear most from germs, namely that they'll kill us. Sean Collins has this account of the battle that his friend Christopher Rose went through with a bug. Christopher grew up in a tiny farming community in central Illinois, but had more of a Noel Coward, kind of personality. A professional musician, he took a turn for the worse, after years, not too long ago.
现在，关于我们体内的细菌的故事，以及我们最担心细菌带来的什么，即它们会杀死我们。肖恩·柯林斯讲述了他的朋友克里斯托弗·罗斯与一种虫子经历的战斗。克里斯托弗在伊利诺伊州中部的一个小农耕社区长大，但性格更像诺埃尔·考沃德。作为一名职业音乐家，几年后，就在不久前，他的情况恶化了。
There is a fact of medicine late in the 20th century that seems absolutely absurd on its face. And it's this, just about the worst place you can be when you're really sick is in the hospital. 5% to 10% of all patients admitted to an American hospital, acquire an infection while they're there.
在20世纪末，医学有一个事实，表面上看起来绝对荒谬。那就是，当你病得很重时，你能在的最糟糕的地方就是医院。所有住进美国医院的病人中，有5%到10%在住院期间感染。
The rate of these so-called nosocomial or hospital-acquired infections is much higher in patients admitted to intensive care units. In fact, a measurable percentage of patients in ICUs die, not of the condition that landed them in the intensive care unit, but from one of these bugs they picked up while they were in the hospital. These germs, more often than not a strain of Staphylococcus aureus, are resistant to most, if not all, antibiotics. And they live there in the hospital. And they got Christopher.
在住进重症监护室的病人中，这些所谓的医院获得性感染率要高得多。事实上，重症监护室中一定比例的病人死去的，不是因为导致他们住进重症监护室的病症，而是因为他们在医院里染上的这些虫子。这些细菌，大多数情况下是金黄色葡萄球菌的一种菌株，对大多数，如果不是全部抗生素具有抗药性。它们住在医院里。它们抓住了克里斯托弗。
If you lie in one position long enough, perhaps in as few as a few days, you're at risk for developing what are called pressure sores, which happen because your weight rests on just a few parts of your body, your butt, your tail bone, the backs of your elbows. What happens is the weight of your body pushes the blood out of the capillaries and your skin in those places. This happens especially if your blood pressure is low, which means the circulatory system doesn't bring as much oxygen to the tissue and it begins to die. The skin literally breaks down. The bugs that live in the hospital love this.
如果你在一个位置躺得够久，也许只要几天，你就有可能发展出所谓的压疮，这发生是因为你的体重只压在身体的几个部位，你的屁股、尾骨、手肘后面。发生的事情是你的身体重量把血液推离了这些地方皮肤的毛细血管。如果你的血压很低，这尤其会发生，这意味着循环系统没有给组织输送足够的氧气，它就开始死亡。皮肤实际上崩溃了。住在医院里的虫子喜欢这个。
These pressure sores are huge gateways to the circulatory system. You might as well put up signs, this way in, this way to the rest of the body. Germs allowed direct access to the bloodstream kind of go wild, eventually growing on things like heart valves and eating away at them. It can cause death literally in a matter of hours. So for patients in ICUs, especially immobile ones, skin care is really important.
这些压疮是通往循环系统的巨大门户。你还不如竖起牌子，从此进入，通往身体其他部分。细菌被允许直接进入血液流，这有点疯狂，最终在心脏瓣膜等东西上生长并腐蚀它们。它确实可以在几个小时内导致死亡。所以对于重症监护室的病人，尤其是不能活动的病人，皮肤护理真的很重要。
Of course, skin care was always important to Christopher. In college, when he didn't have rent money, he had a supply of Clinique products. And now the doctors really didn't want him to lose the defense his skin could provide.
当然，皮肤护理对克里斯托弗来说一直很重要。在大学时，当他没钱付房租时，他有一堆倩碧产品。而现在医生们真的不想让他失去皮肤所能提供的防御能力。
In the end and on his own, Christopher did develop a nasty bed sore. A sample got sent to the lab to be cultured. And it came back positive for an antibiotic resistant bacteria, a strain of staph. As soon as that happened, signs went up on the door in big letters, CONTACT PRECAUTION. It told us to wash our hands upon entering the room and leaving. And to be gloved and gowned if any direct contact with the patient was expected. This was to keep the bug in the room. And to keep it from making forays into other rooms on the unit. And they would routinely draw his blood to see if it made it past his skin, past that last, best defense, and into his bloodstream.
最后，克里斯托弗自己确实长了一个讨厌的褥疮。一个样本被送到实验室进行培养。结果是抗生素耐药性细菌，一种葡萄球菌菌株，呈阳性。一旦发生这种情况，门上就竖起了大写的牌子，接触预防。它告诉我们在进入房间和离开时洗手。如果预计会有任何直接的病人接触，还要戴手套和穿防护服。这是为了把虫子留在房间里。并防止它在病房的其他房间里出没。他们会例行抽他的血，看看它是否通过了他的皮肤，通过了那最后一道最好的防线，进入了他的血液。
Suddenly, all you can think about is every hospital show you've ever seen on television. Just how are you supposed to wash your hands in this situation? I found myself wondering if I should turn the water off with my elbows, or at least use the paper towel when touching the faucet. In the end, you take your cue from the nurses, and you see that soap and water seem to do the trick with a little friction under running water. Nothing too elaborate, really quite quick. But it's amazing how important that one act is in controlling hospital acquired infections.
突然，你能想到的就是你在电视上看到的每一个医院节目。在这种情况下，你到底应该怎么洗手？我发现自己想知道我是否应该用手肘关掉水龙头，或者至少在接触水龙头时使用纸巾。最后，你从护士那里得到暗示，你会看到肥皂和水在流动的水下加一点摩擦似乎就能解决问题。没有什么太复杂的，真的相当快。但这控制医院获得性感染的一举动有多重要，令人惊奇。
The International Society of Infectious Diseases came out with a little book this year on controlling infectious outbreaks in hospitals. A friend of mine worked on that book, which chronicles ways to control infection in the operating rooms and ICUs and the morgue, basically everywhere in the hospital. My friend said that during its production, the working title for the book was Wash Your Hands, Stupid. That was rejected in favor of the more sober, Handbook of Infection Control in the Hospital.
国际传染病学会今年出了一本关于控制医院传染病暴发的小册子。我的一个朋友参与了那本书的工作，它记录了控制手术室、重症监护室和停尸房感染的方法，基本上是医院里的每一个地方。我的朋友说，在制作期间，这本书的暂定名是《洗洗手，笨蛋》。那个被拒绝了，取而代之的是更严肃的《医院感染控制手册》。
Christopher had made it clear that he wanted to be treated aggressively, as long as there existed a real possibility that that treatment would lead somewhere-- his words. So he was aggressively treated. The condition that landed him in the hospital was something called a necrotizing vasculitis, which manifested itself as a sort of creeping paralysis, that began in his feet and worked its way up his legs, to his hips, to his chest, and then from his fingertips, to his hands, to his arms. Day by day, the loss of feeling would progress. Inch by inch, the movement of his extremities first became awkward, then impossible.
克里斯托弗明确表示他想得到积极治疗，只要那种治疗确实存在导致某种结果的真正可能性——他的原话。所以他得到了积极治疗。导致他住进医院的病症是所谓的坏死性血管炎，它表现为一种蠕动性瘫痪，从他的脚开始，向上爬到他的腿，到他的臀部，到他的胸部，然后从他的指尖，到他的手，到他的手臂。日复一日，失去感觉的情况在进展。一寸一寸地，他四肢的活动先是变得笨拙，然后变得不可能。
The metaphor of battle became obvious as his body became a sort of war map. Reports of troop movements were filed by the members of the house staff on the rheumatology service, especially a dreamy, dark-eyed resident Christopher especially liked. Armed with mallets and pins, this otherwise good natured dreamboat would poke and prod and pinch and whack at my friend, all the while maintaining the guise of friendly conversation-- can you feel this, can you move your toes, how about grasping my hand. Good.
随着他的身体变成某种战争地图，战斗的比喻变得明显起来。风湿病科的病房工作人员，尤其是克里斯托弗特别喜欢的一位有着梦幻深色眼睛的住院医生，提交了部队调动的报告。配备了木槌和大头针，这个平时和蔼可亲的梦中情人会戳、捅、捏和敲打我的朋友，同时维持着友好交谈的伪装——你能感觉到这个吗，你能动动你的脚趾吗，试试抓我的手。好。
Christopher wanted to comply with the instructions, but couldn't. The terrain of battle was becoming unfamiliar to him, the fog of war was obscuring the landscape. He was losing ground. They tried something called plasmapheresis, where his blood was removed and cleaned. He said it was to remove the bad humors. All this further weakened his defenses, and the germs took advantage of the cracks in the ramparts.
克里斯托弗想遵照指示，但做不到。战斗的地形对他来说变得陌生，战争的迷雾掩盖了风景。他正在失去阵地。他们尝试了一种叫血浆置换的东西，他的血液被取出并清洗。他说那是为了清除坏体液。所有这些进一步削弱了他的防御，细菌利用了防御工事中的裂缝。
Now about this war metaphor-- the US military has in place at this moment a plan to fight two wars at once, or to fight one big war in two major theaters of action at the same time. Asking the US military to fight three wars at once, would be asking too much. They've said as much. So it was with my friend.
关于这个战争比喻——美国军方目前有一个计划，可以同时打两场战争，或者同时在两个主要行动战区打一场大战争。要求美国军方同时打三场战争，那要求太高了。他们自己都说了。所以我的朋友也是如此。
Besides the creeping paralysis and the bug on his butt, Christopher acquired a pneumonia, a relatively rare type of pneumonia caused by cytomegalovirus. Here's the odd thing about CMV, most of us live with it in our bodies all the time. Hour by hour, we successfully fight it off. Most of us are winning that little battle right now. But people like Christopher, people with immune systems damaged by HIV, they end up dying of a bug they've lived with all their lives.
除了蠕动性瘫痪和屁股上的虫子，克里斯托弗还感染了肺炎，一种由巨细胞病毒引起的相对罕见的肺炎。关于巨细胞病毒，奇怪的是，我们大多数人一直与它共存。每小时，我们都成功地击退它。我们大多数人现在都在赢得那场小战斗。但像克里斯托弗这样的人，免疫系统被HIV破坏的人，他们最终死于一种他们一生都与之共存的虫子。
His pneumonia got progressively worse, his lungs so filled with fluid that they could barely exchange any gases. It was because his pulmonary function was so poor that the decision was made to withdraw treatment and to allow him to die. That was his wish, that if there was no real hope for meaningful recovery, that extraordinary treatment be discontinued. So on a spring evening at the end of March, some three months after he first went into the hospital, his parents, whom he loved so much, and about 20 of his friends, stood around his bed in the ICU, as a technician turned a knob on the ventilator and allowed him to breathe room air instead of a mixture artificially rich in oxygen.
他的肺炎逐渐恶化，肺部充斥着液体，几乎无法交换任何气体。正是因为他的肺功能太差，才做出了停止治疗让他死亡的决定。那是他的愿望，如果真的没有有意义恢复的希望，就停止非凡的治疗。所以在一个三月底的春夜，在他第一次住进医院大约三个月后，他的父母，他如此深爱的父母，以及大约20个朋友，站在他重症监护室的床边，当一名技术员转动呼吸机上的一个旋钮，让他呼吸室内的空气，而不是人工富氧的混合气体。
He stopped taking breaths on his own a few minutes later, even though the ventilator was pushing air in and out of his lungs. Minutes later his heart rate slowed. And then the monitor above his bed tolled an alarm and spat out a strip of paper. Two minutes later, another alarm and another strip of paper. A minute later, one last strip spilled out of the machine and curled to the ground, like a receipt. Someone wondered out loud if it was the hospital bill. I took it home. It says Christopher Rose, 26 March 1998, 19 hours, 53 minutes, asystole. And below that, there's a flat line drawn across the width of the graph paper.
几分钟后，他停止了自主呼吸，尽管呼吸机仍在将空气推入和推出他的肺部。几分钟后，他的心率减慢。然后他床上的显示器发出了报警声，并吐出一张纸条。两分钟后，又是一次报警，又是另一张纸条。一分钟后，最后一张纸条从机器中滑出，卷在地上，就像一张收据。有人大声想知道那是不是医院账单。我把它带回家了。上面写着克里斯托弗·罗斯，1998年3月26日，19小时53分钟，心脏停搏。在那下面，画着一条穿过坐标纸宽度的直线。
We all just sat there for a while. There is an unmistakable look a dead body has. Within just a couple of minutes, the color of the body changes, the skin turns ashen, a luminescent gray. You can see why people have always believed that something has left the body-- spirit, breath, ruha, pneuma, soul.
我们都只是坐在那里。死尸有一种无可误认的外观。仅仅几分钟内，身体的颜色就变了，皮肤变得灰白，一种发光的灰色。你可以看出为什么人们一直相信有什么东西离开了身体——精神、气息、ruha、pneuma、灵魂。
It is no accident we say that someone has expired. Some people walked out of the room. Others stayed. I stayed for a while. And I found myself wondering how long will it survive? How long will the HIV, the virus that caused all this, how long will it stay alive under that dead man's skin?
我们说某人“过期”（去世）并非偶然。有些人走出了房间。其他人留下了。我待了一会儿。我发现自己在想：它会存活多久？艾滋病毒，那种导致这一切的病毒，它会在那个死人的皮肤下存活多久？
I had the distinct and odd feeling that death is a gradual thing, a process. The person is said to have died, but then death begins in earnest at the cellular level. Once the circulation of blood stops, the cells are deprived of oxygen and they begin to die.
我有一种独特而奇怪的感觉，死亡是一件渐进的事情，一个过程。据说那个人已经死了，但死亡是在细胞层面开始的。一旦血液循环停止，细胞就被剥夺了氧气，它们就开始死亡。
But how long would the HIV continue to live after it had killed its host? I did some research. And it turns out the best guess is that the human immunodeficiency virus can survive for many days post-mortem, in tissues preserved under laboratory conditions-- that according to the International Society of Infectious Diseases.
但艾滋病毒在杀死宿主后还会存活多久？我做了一些研究。事实证明最好的猜测是人类免疫缺陷病毒可以在尸体中存活多天，在实验室条件下保存的组织中——根据国际传染病学会的说法。
The truth is we don't know precisely how long the virus survives in a cadaver. It might die in the blood rather quickly, but live in a pocket in the spleen for instance, for a little while longer. We know that it outlives the host for a little while, but not that long, perhaps less than a week.
事实是我们不知道病毒在尸体中到底能存活多久。它可能在血液中死得很快，但会在脾脏的一个口袋里存活一会儿。我们知道它比宿主多存活了一会儿，但没那么长，也许不到一周。
Which brings me to this question, is it worth it? That extra week in a dead man's blood, is it worth all the bother? Is it worth it hitching a ride for the better part of my friend's life, being the source of endless anxiety and pain, only to outlive him by a week at the most, maybe only for a day or so. It hardly seems worth it to me. Christopher lived his entire adult life with this hanging over his head, waiting for this to happen, and the bug won, and then death claimed them all.
这让我产生了一个问题，值得吗？死人血液中那额外的一周，值得所有的麻烦吗？值得搭上我朋友大半辈子的便车，成为无尽焦虑和痛苦的来源，结果只比他多活了一周，也许只有一天左右。在我看来这似乎一点也不值得。克里斯托弗整个成年生活都顶着这个生活，等待着这种情况发生，虫子赢了，然后死亡夺走了他们所有人。
Sean Collins is the Senior Producer of NPR's All Things Considered.
肖恩·柯林斯是美国国家公共电台《所有事情考虑》的资深制作人。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel and July Snyder. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Paul Tough, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett, Sylvia Lemus, and [? Sahini ?] Davenport. Music help today from Mr. John Connors.
我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑杰克·希特、保罗·塔夫、玛吉·罗克林，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自劳拉·多格特、西尔维娅·莱姆斯和 [? Sahini ?] 达文波特。今天的音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯先生。
Special thanks today to penicillin. To buy a cassette copy of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, (312) 832-3380, (312) 832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Well, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website at www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
特别感谢青霉素。要购买此节目或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，(312) 832-3380，(312) 832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected] 。好吧，您可以在我们的网站 www.thislife.org 上免费收听我们的大部分节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who of course refers to the door of the This American Life studio as--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他当然把《美国生活》工作室的门称为——
The portal of death.
死亡之门。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。